I'm here with Jacques our lead front-end
engineer hi hi
so documentation love it hate it you
really need it you all really need it
yeah it's it's not the best it's not the
most fun thing to write it's the most
amazing thing when you start working on
a project and there is documentation so
what about reading documentation reading
documentation is a core thing that
engineers do all the time so if I were
to give you an API or a piece of
software or something like that and ask
you to work with it and let's say that I
didn't allow you to use documentation
with your productivity
Logan also let's say that you are 100
percent productive before without
documentation where would you be
oh be in the 20% range I mean really
yeah well because you're gonna have to
parse I mean it depends on how big the
code is you know I can read through it
and sort of figure out what's what's
going on if I have access to that to
that code if it's not just a black box
but even then you know I mean that means
that I have to go through and fully
understand the inner workings of what
somebody else has come up with and
without documentation that's hard that's
a lot of time spent understanding
something that could have been very
easily handled with this hands back this
object so what would you say to students
who are taking our course who are
learning to read documentation I mean
like I know when I first started
programming I had a huge resistance to
reading documentation and furthermore I
felt like it reflected negatively about
me as a programmer like I don't already
know this I'm looking up string dot
split or something like that which I use
all the time what's wrong with me hmm
absolutely nothing I mean it's it's
programming you know we're making you're
taking an idea about what you want it to
do and you know what you want your code
to do and turning it into reality right
and the nitty-gritty of what the fourth
argument for this built-in API is is not
really an important thing right you know
and if it's something you use literally
all of the time it'll eventually get
stuck in your head and until then just
look it up it's
there's it absolutely does not reflect
poorly on you we look up stuff all the
time and it's stuff from the most arcane
randomness that you can think of all the
way down to how are we gonna split a
string alright I mean that that comes up
and if you don't have it on the top of
your head if it's faster for you to go
look it up than it is to sit there and
try and type a bunch of things into the
console and figure it out go look it up
so it seems almost like it's like
writing with English so if you're
writing a paper and you are looking up a
word for example and you look it up
again and again and again eventually
it'll get stuck in your brain but the
fact that you don't have it the second
time doesn't reflect negatively on you
as a human being right right no
absolutely not I mean as an engineer
your ability to to be an engineer to be
an effective engineer is not that you
have everything committed to memory if
you use something enough it'll be in
there so it's not memorization
absolutely it's building with pieces and
then if you don't remember how to use
the pieces or the tools then you'll look
it up exactly and I mean if you were to
hold up an engineer who knows every
little nitty bit about some package or a
framework or whatever and makes terrible
programming decisions versus somebody
who makes good programming decisions and
looks everything up this guy is the guy
you want on your team yeah yeah that
makes sense all right so don't be afraid
to look things up it's important
absolutely awesome thanks Chuck